it's not good so nathan's getting worse
and i'm just getting better hi i'm nina
and if you know me you know i
love drama i am so excited to announce
the coming of filthy rich
your father not a faithful man he had
three children outside this marriage
three different women filthy rich will
be premiering on monday september 21st
at 9 8 central on fox
in honor of filthy rich we're going to
make two dessert enthusiasts go
head-to-head in a culinary cook-off
where i get to decide which one of them
makes the best southern dessert
now let's introduce our competitors hi
i'm nathan and today i'll be making
lemon beignets and they're going to be a
lot better than whatever tracy is making
hi i'm tracy and today i'm going to make
hummingbird cupcakes
this is my humminbird cake i made it
myself this morning especially for you
all
you only have an hour and a half to make
your desserts
may the best southern dessert win good
luck
i can totally get these cupcakes done in
an hour and a half and i'm ready to win
i only have an hour and a half to make
this and i know it usually takes me two
hours to make it this is gonna be
tougher than hell but i'm confident
they're going to be better than tracy's
hummingbird cupcakes
i'm going to whisk those together and
sometimes people want to skip this step
i feel like if nathan was doing this
he'd probably skip this step and they'd
probably turn out
pretty bad this recipe is a lot more
technical than cupcakes
tell you that much got our dry
ingredients all mixed together
and now i'm going to add my wets smells
a lot better than cupcakes
nathan picked a dumb recipe i'll say it
he has to make a dough with yeast which
takes time to rise he has to fry stuff
he has to fill stuff
i think that my recipe choice is really
what is going to win me the gold here
every time i look at tracy it seems like
she's having a walk in the park she's
just scooping her batter
putting it into her cupcake tins these
are gonna be
sweeter than heaven time to make my
beignet dough
so i've got some warm water and yeast
forgot to add sugar for my yeast so they
had nothing to eat but i did it again
for yeast to work you have to have
something for it to
eat so it seems like he just kind of
never
learned like basic common sense or
something time to combine so it's gonna
look a little
rough and scraggy but that's what we're
looking for
time to transfer it and i will begin
kneading this
cool i think it's looking pretty good
now i'm going to transfer it to a
greased
bowl then i'm going to cover it and let
it proof you only have one hour
remaining easy
i don't need an hour i got all the time
in the world cream cheese frosting so of
course there's cream cheese
softened butter now i'm gonna beat these
together
until they become nice and incorporated
again i'm just waiting for my cupcakes
to cook
nathan's over there waiting for his
dough to rise still
you've got 30 minutes left i'm feeling
great no stress
easy breezy nathan is over there trying
to cut
beignet dough like he's never used a
knife in his life you know what tracy if
i want to do something easy i would have
made cupcakes
literally a piece of cake you have 15
minutes left
okay okay so i got 15 minutes now i'm
just gonna put this on a rack
let them cool then i'm gonna get to
piping and filling these with the lemon
curd
i think i've improved i think these last
ones are looking better than the first
ones though
so nathan's getting worse and i'm just
getting better
you only have five minutes left we're
cutting we're moving oh boy we're
winning
it looks like nathan's never used a
pastry bag or something because he is
just
really struggling i can show you how to
use that
after they announce it in the winter
this is not as easy as i thought it
would be here we go
here we go there it is this is not good
i'm just gonna take
a little slice of the fresh kind of
nestle it in there
and then a little dried slice and nestle
it right beside it
and they might not look perfect but they
definitely look better than nathan's
this is your one minute warning
i only need 15 seconds okay i'm just
gonna pick
three of the best looking ones just
quick dusting
powdered footer last one
beautiful boom and time
boom lemon beignets food is
love bring your desserts over to me and
set them right on this table
thank you so much for bringing me these
desserts
all right the beignets in terms of
presentation
i think it's plated very simply but in a
very
kind of classic way thank you the color
is
very lovely they're a nice kind of
golden brown and they look like
they'll have a nice little crisp on the
outside but then just kind of give way
as you want a beignet to
do i have no problem with minimalism as
long as the
food itself stands up to the test okay
okay i have to say these cupcakes look
pretty spectacular thank you the
frosting element is very beautiful
takes a lot of effort to make and
decorate
12 cupcakes versus three vinnies
in terms of presentation the cupcakes
are really blowing me away
so now i'm gonna start tasting these
desserts and
i think i'll start with the beignets
oh that's a good beignet it's very
lemony i wish there was
i think even more lemon curd in this
because the lemon curd part is really
good
and i think honestly this beignet could
use more of it
so now i'm gonna move on to the cupcakes
wow this frosting is sweeter than heaven
i really appreciated the
decor element it's very pretty for
presentation but it is more of an
obstacle to eat
okay both of these desserts were very
delicious
however only one of them can be the best
southern dessert nathan your beignets
were a wonderful mix of the simplicity
of a classic
beignet with the little extra oomph of
the tasty lemon curd on the inside
but i have to say tracy's cupcakes
truly blew me away down to the
presentation
was out of this world so
these cupcakes are definitely my winner
yes
sorry nathan i knew i would win
mostly because i knew nathan would lose
listen tracy may have won
but the time crunch whatever plus nina's
taste buds are probably off i know i had
the better dessert at the end of the day
thanks so much for joining us today we
hope you enjoyed our cook off
be sure to check out filthy rich
premiering monday september 21st
at 9 8 central on fox